welch ein unrühmliches welch ein
schändliches finale einer mehr als
turbulenten präsidentschaft donald trump
was sich gestern im kapitol in
washington ereignet hat was sich auf den
stufen des gebäudes ereignet hat das so
eine große symbolische pornografische
bedeutung für die politische kulturen
die amerikanische demokratie hat das ist
ehrlich gesagt unvorstellbar viele leute
fragen sicher hätte man sich das
vorstellen kann und man muss
ehrlicherweise sagen man hat viel
darüber gelesen hat darüber gelesen dass
möglicherweise wenn es zum äußersten
kommt ein bürgerkrieg drohe das milizen
nach washington marschieren
aber wenn man dann auch ehrlich ist muss
man sagen man hat sich das nicht
wirklich vorstellen können in einem land
das die vormacht der demokratischen
staaten welt ist das sich selbst als
stadt auf dem hügel versteht das
sozusagen demokratische zensuren überall
verteilt und das auch inspiration nach
wie vor für zig millionen menschen auf
der welt ist das ein wahlergebnis vom
präsidenten dazu ermuntert von wählern
quasi in einer aufstand auf ähnlichen
aktion torpediert werden soll
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist beispiellos in amerikanischen
geschichte das ist für westliche staaten
eine um ein ungeheuer traumatisches
erlebnis würde ich fast sagen gott sei
dank ist es nicht soweit gekommen es ist
dann doch unter dem eindruck der
ereignisse von auch von republikanischen
senatoren und abgeordneten die einsicht
gewachsen dass das nicht so weiter kann
amerika war gestern glaube ich nur
wenige meter vor dem abgrund bei einer
dauerhaften beschädigung der
amerikanischen demokratie entfernt und
manche haben doch mit schrecken gesehen
woran sie selbst mitgewirkt haben was
sie nicht verhindert haben dass sie dem
präsidenten haben gewähren lassen über
so viele jahre hat es so kommen müssen
man kann vor allem zwei dinge sagen
der präsident ist ein populist und der
populist lebt davon dass er eskaliert
dass er seine rhetorik immer aggressiver
werden lässt dass er radikalisiert und
gestern in den straßen und auf dem
kapitolshügel in washington war ein
aufgesetzter mob am werke es gibt in
amerika und ein soziokulturelles milieu
viele millionen weiße wähler die für
solche sachen empfänglich sind
man muss nicht nur sagen dass es unter
schichten wähler sind um gottes willen
und nicht alle fehler sind analysiert
viele sind normale anständige leute
selbstverständlich aber es ist ein
beachtlicher teil des amerikanischen
elektro rad in einem milieu beheimatet
dass das genaue gegenteil ist vom
amerikanischen journalismus gewalt affin
in drogen milieus und ich rede von einem
weißen elektro hat
in dem rassismus sozusagen nach wie vor
nicht unbekannt ist usw
und dieses kam alles zusammen vier jahre
tram vier jahre mobilisierende agitieren
radikalisierenden rhetorik entsprechende
handlungen mit einer verachtung für
gewaltenteilung mit der verachtung für
institutionen mit einer sozusagen um
verständnis von verfassungen dass wenn
es dem präsidenten nicht passt wie eine
beleidigung ist und das ist gestern
quasi explodiert die letzten wochen
waren haben das vorbereitet war betrug
wahlbetrug wahlbetrug war seine
geschichte und viele viele wähler in
amerika haben ihm das abgenommen gott
sei dank ist es ist dieser schritt nicht
vollzogen worden aber für joe biden den
künftigen präsidenten wird es sehr sehr
schwer sein diese milieus sozusagen
zurück zu einer von zu einem kurs der
vernunft der mitte zu bringen und diese
verfeindeten lager zu überwinden das
wird sehr schwer werden